for the last of parliament's hearings
France timberman's first vice president
designate and first back stop in a
college of Commissioners that jeanclaude
junker wants to deliver better laws
better connected to Citizens first
though a bit of a linguistic showstopper
from the Dutch foreign minister thank
you for your
question
then the key issue we need to restore
our citizens confidence in the capacity
of the EU to deliver how exactly three
measures to start with by the end of
next year I hope to conclude an
interinstitutional agreement on better
lawmaking we need greater transparency
within the Brussels bubble which is why
I will promote an interinstitutional
agreement on a mandatory Lobby register
I believe Commissioners should engage
more directly in dialogues with national
parliaments over next PS for questions
ranging across many fields Beyond
these this is a clear and present danger
to the security of all Europeans this is
a primary responsibility obviously of
Our member states from the Socialist
leader a question on the citizens
initiative and efforts to narrow the gap
between the and its
citizens and on the human rights
question I wonder if you were aware of
the great anger and resentment in the
United Kingdom at the perverse
consequences of the European convention
on human rights we have criminals
terrorists murderers and rapists whom we
cannot Deport this is has been an
invaluable instrument an invaluable
instrument in creating rights for people
all across um the European area and yes
there are downsides and I think we need
to discuss those downsides there was
plenty of talk about fundamental rights
but it's just one part of Mr timberman's
broad brief another pressing task to
improve often shaky relations between
the eu's big three institutions the
council the commission and the
Parliament